[Music]
and welcome back to another Fitness
episode of the careful boys where we
have Mr Jared and Dr Mike over here
everybody the brightest M greatest it's
all brain no Brown over here
so we want to talk about Fitness
influencers we want to talk about the
good and the bad we heard you guys were
talking about a couple on your guys'
show on you guys' YouTubes and you know
I'm I'm curious about Fitness nowadays
and I you know I'll be going down the
gram I'll be going on YouTube I'll be
looking at stuff you know I'm going to
admit some stuff and you could tell me
if they're cool or not I've seen some
videos from like this dude I forget his
name but he's uh does aen X is that a
good one huh be honest oh Mr Jeff
Cavalier that's one guy Cavalier
cavali oh [__] wait is he the keto guy
or the the the the in minuted uh he
looks like he's 100 years old but he PT
guy yeah he's a PT guy that says a lot
of stuff about physical therapy yeah
yeah yeah and he takes markers and he
draws the different cations of his
[__] muscles and stuff to show you
what's Co probably 70 or 80% of a [__]
is just right on and it's just totally
good um but some fraction of his stuff
is like questionable whether or not like
so he'll make claims like don't do this
movement cuz it'll get you hurt and
you're like if you know things like
Jared and I do we like we give that like
Thomas soul like it's by no means clear
face anyone who catches that please
comment I love you a
million is an economist yeah we're
really nerdy we don't have friends in
room I know who he is we have parasocial
relationship okay well say 7 70% is
still pretty 7% is pretty good over
index on the [__] he tells you not to do
you're just like getting it's like
someone who's like okay eat super
healthy run a lot do push-ups it's great
great never ever ever talk to people
named Bob ever and you're like okay that
seems kind of out of place
what's die children are going to die and
you're like okay well the rest of the
[__] sounds the other 70% was good yeah
cuz he's like he'll be like oh like you
know do squats and deadlifts and eat
well and you're like oh it's great and I
try this row it works great oh my God he
can't miss and he's like if you do one
upright row your shoulders will detonate
thermonuclear shoulder war will occur
you're going to die people around you
are going to die and you're like that
makes you question the reason
it makes you question reasonable but as
as educated sport scientists we're here
to tell you that he's chalk full of
reasonable [__] but now you have a
problem you filtering problem you don't
know being not expert [__] like
you just looking people maybe that's
just the fact that he's got to be like
constantly content creation you got you
got to spin that [__] that's what I
thought too is like you eventually get
kind of like there's a cap to how much
you can say the same things right or
like what else are they going to create
I don't know F there's always new
audience though that's why he's kind of
catching wind again to be honest he's
saying a lot of the same [__] he said
back when I was in high school but it's
just new videos saying a different way
so who are some of your favorite uh
people that are out there like same
Fitness [__] Renaissance
periodization oh jez Jer
self it's like yes mostly on there
really I'm I like that I always like
Michael Jackson's Fitness advice yeah he
was
good he's great about youth
Fitness okay why is that so funny it's
cuz me and him we go back and forth on
Michael Jackson oh my God
[__] the rest of this
conversation we go we me and Joe debate
honestly so um the guy who runs our our
YouTube channel Scott the video guy him
and I go back and forth about Michael
Jackson I just can't stand it what's
your St stance okay my stance was
originally
neutral then my friend Ashley Ashley K
you know who you are she was like Hey
you would find this 4H hourong
documentary on HBO MH Finding Neverland
whatever the [__] it was called yeah we
found that [__] too it turns out a
couple of [__] little kids found it a
bit early if you feel me and it was not
unpopulated place there was a population
one Mr Michael Jackson and you know the
population density was very high he's
very close to the children enough
allegory that for if you haven't seen it
and you love Michael Jackson's music and
you think that the world is morally
neutral and you're okay knowing bad
things happen but you don't care about
them like you eat meat you're okay with
like you know defensive Warfare just
don't ever watch those four hours I
watched it over and over and I think
it's fake as [__] oh [__] we got a
conspiracy he got the video guys the
same way he refuses to even acknowledge
that there were documentaries she's like
oh you mean by those Liars who lied and
said in court that Michael Jackson
didn't do anything and I was like he's
like in a court of law and I'm like
people lie in court all the time he's
like nonsense Michael Jackson's innocent
cuz Michael Jackson like there's levels
to music and this [__] done
broke through all of them like he is
and so it's tough to blame him for the
completely heinous insane and obvious
over evidenced [__] he's done to dozens
of children it's not dozens it's only
three I'm like what do you really do
tell them to bend over so he could touch
his own self like I me come on he did
all kinds of [__] like that yeah you
only had a little Jesus Juice with them
I don't see what the problem with that
is and you guys don't enjoy a good
sleepover I don't understand and Joe's a
plus or minus three kids guy just in
case
it's all like it's all hazy in that
range you never know you know yeah you
know listen I wish I had never known
that [__] about Michael Jackson cuz the
first time I heard chin is not my son
Billy Jean after the [__] it was kind of
like in like [__] uh Blackhawk Down
when the guy gets up and there's a guy
like and he can't
hear that's how I heard [__] Billy
Jean after that I was just like oh my
God that's not good cuz you know he was
like the chid is not my son Jared now
talking about in the
car I believe you I believe you cuz he
was not looking for a het of res sexual
relationships with women you can't
remove the artist and the human they
found porn they found porn in his house
he likes
porn it was all child porn porn it's
regular porn porn dude he had layers of
[__] like making sure people didn't
find out did you guys know that Michael
Jackson has no biological children
blanket what really that's a conspiracy
Google Google that does Google a
conspiracy who does who does blanket or
Paris who do they who do they belong to
blanket and Paris biological children
really really that's what I've been L to
believe someone else believe it though
someone else dad legit you ever see that
that interview with Michael Jackson
Marie Presley's children who's the dad
the conspiracy is that it's one of his
friends that impregnated her for him
it's not his actual kid look like
Michael at all father oh yeah well based
off of this they needed 23 of me I would
say based off like I would imagine BL
pick music you know you think they'll
share that Harrison Prince's mother
Debbie row has publicly stated Michael
Jackson is not his children's biological
father days after Michael Jackson's
death in 2009 at the age of 50 his
ex-wife Debbie Rose spoke to a British
tablet about nothing but net and then uh
blanket was born to another surrogate
mother who had no idea Jackson would be
the father I don't know what that
statement means that's complicated
not my son he said it early he was right
wait so it's not uh Lisa Marie Presley's
kid says a serate whose identity has
never been disclosed blanket who now
goes by BG you know it was PYT that
[__] it up for really why yeah cuz I
thought pretty young a girl sure he
is he's talking about young like 18 to
22 also I told myself that but I will
tell you what it doesn't matter the jam
is still a jam Joe he [__] Michael
jackon again like that [__] comes on and
you're like I hate [__] pedophiles
all those piece of [__] they all need to
burn and the [__] the [__] like
[__] what's that [__] like Thriller
comes on and all of a sudden I'm doing
this [__] I'm like I can't stop baby
like I'm a monster
too he was a real
monster kind worth it though if
everything about Disney was true all
that [__] Walt Disney yeah wasn't you
like an anti-semite well and also just
like they they try say like
pedopilia has opinions godamn it like
pedophilia all that [__] you telling me
I'm just I'm never going to put on
another Disney movie while I have a nice
young lady over we're going to watch
CoCo together not because she's Latina
yeah he's not going to watch the movie
yeah come on if the movie is in set of
course I'm watching the [__] movie
yeah I'm going to watch all the Disney
movies yeah yeah I know cuz the
animators weren't all pedopiles I don't
care 100% of that's for real I'm
watching the movies I removed the the
master from their crime that's right uh
Hugo Boss I think designed the Naz
uniforms and that's why they look so
cool they look [__] great terrible
people amazing [__] drip
Swag like it's just OD I like you boss
doesn't [__] miss it
just they killed with did you know the
bug was designed by Hitler and his crew
yeah that's whack thumbs down dude
today's video is brought to you by
Uncommon Goods are you tired of the same
old gifts buying the same old Christmas
sweaters the back scrubbers that your
grandma don't need we'll check out
Uncommon Goods cuz they got unique
holiday gifts for everybody Uncommon
Goods often carries a lot of cool unique
items from artists and handmade Goods
right here made in the US yeah
everything small batch super unique and
you can find something for old young
lesbian whatever you're into whatever
check it out over here here's an example
Mochi donut kit and you know they sent
this to us cuz we're Asian right yep
they're not being racist they're just
thought it matched and I think that they
actually nailed it cuz I love this it's
from Mr Morimoto you know him he's so
famous yeah so imagine getting a gift
like this then the fin then the family
gets the bond everyone gets to hang out
and it's way better than getting Ginger
ice cre cream which no one wants to eat
anyways and look at that it's signed
it's got matcha it's got cocoa flavor
it's got strawberry you can make Mochi
Donuts at home and have fun with the
whole family to get 15% off your next
gift go to uncommongoods.com sloff thee
that's uncommongoods.com sloff thec for
15% off don't miss out on this limited
time offer Uncommon Goods we're all out
of the ordin
well I want a VW bus those are the worst
bus not the bus I want the bus I want
the bus want some white women with
armpit hair too to go along that shag
I shag all right I'll take the white
girls not the hair really openhearted
people that just love to love love to
love I see them a lot in
Hawai they usually have they usually
have a pocket full of crystals too yes
crystals are good you always got to keep
going around H yeah just in case just in
case nothing effect will be around this
one's for Success this one this is for
wealth they're like projecting their
success they're like
manifesting but you also got have to
charge them you have to leave them out
in the sun so they can charge so they
have energy that's how they charge
them was it called The Law of Attraction
is my wife and I were watching dating
shows what is that is that where you
like whatever you put out there comes to
you yes and this's one guy describing it
and
un there was one of the yeah that's
right right there was these two people
what's it called like love island or
some [__] like that and there's like a
Korean version which is dope as [__] but
then that we watch in the regular
American version and these two people
met up you know cuz they put on many
dates on the [__] Island and they're
like like what are you up to blah blah
blah and in two seconds they were like
yeah like Law of Attraction whatever
like oh I'm totally into that and I was
like the [__] so we paused it Googled it
and we were like so law of attraction is
like whatever like Vibes you put out
into the world are going to come back
tfold you can if you really think that
you're schizophrenic I don't know what
else to tell you like you don't have a
non-physical effect on the outside world
you're 8 years old developmentally or
you're off the [__] cliff and you
need medical attention and both of these
young beautiful adults are like yep I'm
into that [__] dude if I was on that
dating show and she was like I'm into
law of attraction it be like [__] like
gravitation and [__] she's like no no no
she described it i' be like I got to
[__] not me able to consent they got IQ
under 100 say what they all have a IQ
under 100 on those shows I swear to God
that for it cuz yeah you're too smart
get the [__]
out 100% they know how to pick on dude
they know to pick I don't have enough
game to be on a show like that being
honest for some reason I think you might
kill it yeah dud i' I'd fold up I'd
[__] I don't think those like goes
IND your [__] just back in I just be
like that time like like just a totally
just get my neurotic Jew character a new
girl comes in the show like oh she's
beautiful
hi my name is Mike
the guys on those shows man again um
maybe the straightest person ever yeah
talking about like like railroad not the
[__] that turns either the straight St
one way downtown Pittsburgh like that
and we were watching those dating shows
my wife and I and I'm like yeah the
girls are fine as they're all fine as
hell whatever seen one you seen them all
type of [__] the
boys like look like I am so straight I
am so straight they're all like charming
and [__] and they're beautiful are they
real alpha males but subtly bro like one
of them like cuz like I've kind of out
I'm the as b as Alpha look like I look
like a [__] whatever nobody's going
to add Alpha me on a [__] show but I
was on a show and a [__] was like what up
I be the [__] he just be
like my ears look like they do I look
like I'm been in a few fist fights the
[__] out of my face no no no it wasn't
that it was this one guy was like
putting this [__] hardcore game down
on this [__] and he was like the most
ey lasered [__] ever he was like
I really just find you exceptionally
attractive creep yo bro no no but he was
so [__] beautiful he did it with so
much goddamn conviction he cooked her
ass he just cooked her on live TV he's
like I'm really unun and I really think
we should do something and she's just
like okay okay the good looks already
did have the work [__] and I was like if
I was her I would be peeing myself yeah
with
lust The Law of Attraction Laws of
Attraction he's got to put it out there
dude soon as he put it out oh we were
talking about Fitness influencers but
this is good yo oh yeah they end up
being Fitness influ dud some of those
guys are famous influencers really yeah
like cuz like okay so truth be told when
I watch these shows mostly I'm high as
[__] cuz like sober I'm just like these
people are [__] idiots watch Dum
watch if you're high I understand I'm
like I get all the in like the
psychodynamics and they're all primates
and it's great so one one of the times
is n watching a zoo I'm going to watch
it tonight
so I'm high as [__] with my wife who's
sober and uh putting up my [__] and
we're watching one of these shows and
I'm like wait a minute these are real
people this is like 2021 the show was
filmed and I'm like cuz to me they're
famous as soon as you're on TV holy [__]
yeah and then I was like wait a minute
let's go look at their Instagrams or
whatever and like they got less
following than I do and they're like in
Fitness sort of like I they might know
who I am yeah and because one of those
guys walked up to me in like dragons
lair in Vegas was like Dr Mike I follow
[__] be like
I'm peeing L but he doesn't break eye
contact and he just staring at you the
whole time oh my God I'm like a [__]
hot dog in don't worry I pre-cooked I'm
already [__] ready on the
inside we have some fans that are were
on a 90-day fiance really and I was like
damn that's crazy we watch you it was on
the other way you know when they go to
their
country it's called like 90day fiance
the other way yeah no functioning sewer
system and [__] like
that why would you want come through
America with me some fine ass people in
countries like that that's where Jerry's
gone there's a humanitarian disaster and
it's got brown women in it Jerry's there
moving bricks and [__] build the poorer
the country the more beautiful everyone
is I should it's a good idea we going to
make a farm we got this all planned out
really where here or southeast Asia what
do we
here there like a network bring them
from quality of life I me I like that
less giant
centipedes more sewage systems yeah more
seage system jar let's talk about the
pluses and minuses of getting you to
Vietnam on the plus side Vietnamese
girls let's game
over yeah total respect total respect if
you're a [__] if you're a woman and
whatever race you are I don't care and
you think you're fine there's always a
Vietnamese [__] that's going to
outshine you she's there she's like
wherever you walk into some club and
you're like oh my God I'm hot [__] some
vietnames girl walks by you're like what
angels and then and then so you're Jared
right so you're like I'm there the Jarry
force and then you were looking at like
the tour guide thing in the airport for
Vietnam and it's like oh like our spirit
animal and it's real and it's everywhere
is the [__] foot long giant centi and
you're
like but the
girls just go to Westminster or or Texas
Houston there's enough here Vietnamese
Americans are different oh really yeah
authentic wait why are they different we
just got him some heavy racism you just
wave that right off no I'm just saying
there's a lot of them is all I'm saying
viese girls in America dude
they that's what he likes oh he loves
that yeah you did oh
no back to Michigan or whatever yes this
is your flavor you know it just happened
cuz the Vietnamese girls here is
everybody's noral of Vietnamese but the
inside of a Latina that's everywhere
that's Jerry's ultimate
girl come on over to Garden
Grove you need to go to Houston then
Houston
Westminster Santa
Ana there's many many vietnames I think
just coming on the show is really open
it's an Outreach can you do like a
presidential candidacy speech on here
like dear uh Brown women of the world I
I'm Jared feather and I want to be
elected as your superhero God and I will
make sweet love to each and every one of
you if I'm appointed we have to do this
right there man there's always a Jew wri
in the
[Laughter]
[__] you can't underhand pitch me the
[__] like this that's true bow oh [__]
need a Jew rball
dude well except I'm Jewish so I miss
the te spraying my ankle I know the the
Best Orthopedist that's a typical like
if you're like a New York Jew guy sounds
really racist but I'm Jewish remember
you can't cancel me for this [__] um
you're always like getting treatment for
minor [__] that you're not supposed to
have at your age but you brag to people
to make up for it by how good the
[__] orthopedist is Mor High what
happened to your ankle I don't know I
woke up at night and it was swollen I'm
getting it treated but the the same
doctor that does the New York Jets and
you're like my God for how awful your
genetics are being alive and in one
shape you sure do have connections with
the best that's what matters
sry true oh man this is funny because I
used to work at a mortgage company with
a lot of Jewish dudes you said it all
already with how long is my stereotype
but we we would compete Asians versus
Jews everyone loses
downhill who would get more
who can be more neurotic Jews are like
oh Asian like I'm not
neurotic I just don't tell anyone about
it Jews [__] Asians have the same am of
neurosis but they just keep it all
in